this one's kind of interesting and it's
a little bit off topic and it's been
brought to my attention from a bunch of
different sources that we have these
Elites right now these billionaires I
think Mark Mark Zuckerberg is probably
the most recent one who became a
billionaire in the 2000s what 15 you
know years ago roughly whatever happens
have been has been a billionaire for 15
odd years and has never built a bunker
why do we have all these Elites right
now building high-end bunkers it was it
was just publicized that he's putting
one together in his uh compound in
Hawaii why like what do they know that
we don't know you know it's a question
that I'm asking this is just something
that I've noticed buzzing about
lately and it's forc me to ask questions
like what about the
preparedness for myself for my inner
circle for the guys of my community so I
have some conversations to have about
that but I just wanted to table this as
an observation that I noticed this past
year we've got a lot of these very
wealthy people right now uh publicly
admitting that they are
building bunkers call them whatever you
want the [__] hits the fan the next
invented item whatever it is what do
they know that we don't know or is it
just that they're sitting on so much
money they're like [__] it I'll build a
million doll bunker or $10 million
bunler you know whatever it happens to
be that they're putting
together rais this question though right
the other thing I've noticed this year
is there is no letting up people always
ask about trajectories and curves and
predictions and stuff like that and
there is absolutely no letting up in
fact the push has become harder on the
pacification of the West I have a video
on the entrepreneurs and cars Channel
that I did seven years ago where I
predicted this where I saw the general
pacification the softening of the
western male starting to occur you can
go back it's on the YouTube channel it's
it's on entrepreneurs and cars and the
the title of the video is why are
Western men so soft and the picture in
the thumbnail is the pacification of the
western maale it's a Google search you
can't miss it so I predicted this
whatever it was seven years
ago this this this push is getting
harder and harder every single year
we're seeing men get softer and weaker
we're seeing obvious signs testosterone
levels are dropping estrogen levels are
climbing more men are shaped like pairs
more men have female breast tissue more
men are you know they got fat around
their they they're gutten nothing going
on you rest her body there are glimmers
of Hope like I go to the gym or I'll go
to the dojo and everybody in that space
that goes on a regular basis looks good
they look like they're competent they
look like they're ready to fight they
understand the need for masculinity or
competence and the ability to wage
violence you know if you know what I'm
saying you know they always say that
it's that it's far better to walk softly
and carry a big stick you understand
what I'm saying
right so that trenel is
continuing the Canadian federal
government and its Infinite Wisdom
Justin Chau has decided to mandate that
all employers have tampons in men's
bathrooms this is where Society is going
this is where culture is going the
federal government has already done this
with um its bathrooms or is working
towards implementing it in every single
bathroom they have but as I understand
it the Mandate has extended Tolo
employers as well where they'll be
forced to offer uh female sanitary
napkins to men in the
bathroom I don't know what is a greater
insult or an observation of the
pacification of the western male than
that but it is a reality of the world
that we live in
today I you know I think
about men's bathrooms when I was a
kid there
was I mean we would we would just rip it
off the wall you know we would just
laugh at it R rip it off the wall
graffiti it that's the way that you know
we were back then because we didn't cow
toow or bend the knee to any of these
bizarre narratives but this is where we
are today a federal government is
mandating female sanitary napkins in
men's bathrooms in
workspaces you figure that one out see
how that makes sense for the what the
0.00001% of the North American
population that is a Transformer I don't
know you you figured out and you tell
me the uh ladies night show has been
very
interesting I did a year in you know
recap with moff and you know we had a
awesome conversation about some of the U
Reflections we've had in the past year
and I think it's worth worth mentioning
as well since a lot of you guys are
calling in and asking questions about
your issues with dating and
relationships and that sort of stuff
that there is a very strong push as well
on the on the opposite side of the
spectrum you know like I said there's a
softening of the western male there's a
strengthening or a masculinization of
the western
female even women that come off as
conventionally feminine and you'll see
them in the ladies night's cast long
hair makeup um you know the Optics of
femininity Beauty you know hips weight
push-up bras all that sort of stuff
you'll see them there um
but there's a strong strong push with a
lot of these gals towards you know I've
talked about boss girls boss [__] you
know whatever the hashtag is that
happens to be trending um you know these
women that are so strong and independent
that they're essentially turning
themselves into men you asked some
questions during the show like you know
hey you know what are you bring to the
table sort of thing in a relationship
and the the very common response always
goes down the path of well I'm
successful I have a career I have my
degree I have my own place I have my own
car my place is decorated pretty you
know like the S like the standard sort
of stuff and what they're essentially
describing is a dude they've they've
been con convinced through a function
and a and a long sequence of comforting
lies that being a compliment to a guy's
life being useful
uh being you know respectful to a man
and uh forming a long-term pair bond
should not be a priority your priority
should be chasing Excellence climbing
the corporate ladder don't serve a man
at home serve a man in the corporate
world line his pockets with gold you
know don't don't serve a guy in a
household because that because that
would be wrong so we're seeing this
masculinization of women to a degree
that you know mark my words you know
like I like I said s years ago when I
was was talking about the pacification
of the western maale you know mark my
words today this this push is going to
continue with the masculinization of the
western female they're going to
certainly continue pushing you know I
don't need no
man it's just that's just where we're
going I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out